[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Bei uns ist gerade das Wetter wieder richtig schön!
Zeit zum Grillen!
Okay, wir grillen auch, wenn das Wetter nicht so schön ist.
Aber, wenn die Sonne da ist,
dann grillt man umso lieber.
Heute gibt es ein Kebab-Rezept vom Grill.
Und zwar habe ich mir da jetzt eins
aus meinem türkischen Kochbuch rausgesucht:
Adana Kebabi.
Adana Kebabi Kebab kennen vielleicht viele von euch.
Das gibt es oft beim Türken.
Vielleicht auch auf einem Türkeibesuch.
Und zwar sind das diese langen, großen,
scharfen Kebab-Spieße.
Also wir machen jetzt heute eine große Menge.
Denn das ganze Team isst mit.
Deswegen brauche ich jetzt
zwei Kilo Lammfleisch,
ein halbes Kilo Lammfett.
Das habe ich jetzt einfach separat gekauft
beziehungsweise abgetrennt.
Denn der Fettgehalt im Kebab ist wirklich wichtig,
damit zum einen der Spieß gut hält
und eben auch wegen dem Geschmack.
Dann brauche ich noch vier Zwiebeln,
vier rote Paprikaschoten,
– die sind nicht scharf –
vier Knoblauchzehen,
Salz und Pfeffer,
Chili,
Kreuzkümmel
und Isot.
Isot, das wird auch Urfa Biber genannt.
Isot ist einfach auch eine bestimmte Art von Chili.
Die müsst ihr nicht nehmen, könnt sie aber nehmen.
Die ist einfach richtig schön schwarz.
Also man sieht es schon.
Und zwar ist es eine Chilischote, die wirklich
so lange gereift wird
oder so lange reift,
bis sie dunkel ist.
Und durch den bestimmten Trocknungsprozess an der Sonne
wird das eben schön dunkel.
Nachts wird es dann noch mal eingepackt.
Also es fermentiert auch wirklich richtig lange.
Chiliflocken habe ich jetzt auch
aus unserem Garten, die getrockneten.
Daher nicht so viel,
denn unsere Chilis waren mega scharf.
Und ansonsten gibt es erst mal nichts zu beachten.
Ja.
Bei der Paprika nehme ich jetzt hier die Kerne raus.
Die Zwiebeln und die Knoblauchzehe
kann ich schon mal schälen.
Und jetzt braucht ihr gleich entweder einen Fleischwolf
oder einfach ein richtig scharfes Messer.
Denn
das Hackfleisch wird jetzt selbst zubereitet.
[Musik]
Die Knoblauchzehe am besten ein bisschen zerdrücken.
Und dann
lässt sie sich einfacher schälen.
Oh, die Zwiebeln steigen mir schon wieder in die Augen!
Ich versuche es immer zu verhindern.
Aber es geht nicht!
>> JOSH: Sollen wir dir mal so eine Taucherbrille holen?
>> SALLY: Ja, so einen Taucherbrille mit Nase drin.
So.
Jetzt aber schnell.
So. Das Gemüse ist jetzt erst mal vorbereitet.
Ich schneide es noch grob,
denn das kommt bei mir
auch gleich einfach in den Fleischwolf,
damit es einfach durch die Öffnung gleich passt.
Aber zuerst kommt das Fleisch durch.
Und das Fleisch jetzt einfach in lange Stränge schneiden.
So kann es der Fleischwolf besser zerkleinern.
Also nicht in kleine Würfel, sondern eher länglich.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier auch noch das Fett ein bisschen zerkleinern.
Bei einem kleineren...
Also bei einer kleineren Portion
würde ich es jetzt auch mit dem Beil einfach fein hacken.
Aber ich nehme jetzt echt gleich den Fleischwolf.
Denn die Riesenmenge,
dann stehe ich ja übermorgen noch da.
Daher nehmen wir gleich einen Fleischwolf dazu.
Ich habe jetzt hier vorne am Fleischwolf
eine etwas grobe Scheibe, also nicht ganz fein,
und kann jetzt hier das Fleisch zerkleinern.
[Musik]
Und gar nicht stopfen,
sondern wirklich hier oben eher reingleiten lassen.
Und die Schnecke im Fleischwolf,
die packt sich dann diesen langen Strang
und zieht es dann durch.
Also da muss man eigentlich gar nicht drücken.
>> SAMIRA: Die sehen wie kleine Würmer aus.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ab und zu dann Fett dazu geben.
Dann vermischt es sich auch gleich.
[Musik]
So. Das ist jetzt das letzte Stück.
Und jetzt kann ich hier hinterher
direkt das Gemüse durch geben.
So bekommt ihr nämlich auch alle Fleischreste gut raus.
Ihr könnt auch immer ganz gerne,
wenn ihr zum Beispiel dann noch Frikadellen machen wollt,
noch Semmelbrösel hinterher machen,
also einfach altes Brot durch geben.
Dann bleibt einfach nichts mehr im Fleischwolf hängen.
Da nehme ich aber gleich doch
den Stopfer ein bisschen dafür.
Nicht zum Stopfen, sondern eher zum Anschieben.
Der Fleischwolf ist übrigens nicht immer nur ein Fleischwolf.
Also er ist auch ein guter Gemüsezerkleinerer.
Im Englischen heißt der auch nicht Fleischwolf,
sondern Alleszerkleinerer.
Also
ist eigentlich auch echt gut für Veganer geeignet,
weil man kann damit Falafel machen
und Gemüsefrikadellen und alles
und Spritzkuchen.
[Musik]
Hier kommen jetzt alle Gewürze rein.
Salz,
Pfeffer.
Da wirklich nicht sparen mit den Gewürzen!
Chili gebe ich jetzt, wie gesagt, erst mal nur wenig rein,
weil es mein eigenes gezüchtetes Chili ist.
Und es ist wirklich sehr scharf!
Ansonsten hätte ich jetzt hier
acht Esslöffel Chili reingegeben,
also so dieses Pul Biber,
was man vielleicht vom Türken kennt,
weil das nicht ganz so scharf ist.
Und jetzt alles schön verkneten.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist die Masse fertig.
Die ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen weich,
dadurch dass ich ja die Paprika drin habe
und
die Paprika eben auch so nass war.
Und, wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr jetzt gerne ein bisschen Semmelbrösel dazu geben.
Ist zwar jetzt nicht so ganz original,
aber ich finde,
gerade, wenn man die frische Paprika dazu nimmt,
darf man sich da gerne etwas helfen.
Oder einfach vorher die Paprika entsaften.
Das geht auch.
Aber das wäre jetzt, glaube ich,
ein zu großer Aufwand.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt hier.
Und dann nehme ich eine kleine Menge raus
und brate die schon mal an,
damit ich schauen kann, ob es vom Gewürz her passt.
So mache ich es auch,
wenn ich Frikadellen mache zum Beispiel.
Entweder in einem kleinen Schälchen
und dann kurz in die Mikrowelle,
einfach, dass das Hackfleisch durch ist,
oder kurz in der Pfanne anbraten.
Und dann könnt ihr nämlich probieren,
ob Salz, Pfeffer, die Schärfe, ob alles passt.
Ich mache das jetzt kurz in der Mikrowelle.
[Musik]
Mh.
Also ich finde, es geht noch ein bisschen Chili.
Weil
momentan ist es noch nicht scharf.
Nee, ich lasse es
wegen den Kindern.
Und dann kann ja jeder selber noch Chili darauf geben.
Ja.
Ich habe jetzt hier diese Riesen-Adana-Spieße.
Die könnt ihr nehmen.
Oder ihr nehmt einfach kleine.
Dann habt ihr schöne kleine Portionen.
Ich finde die auch ganz süß.
Wichtig ist einfach nur, dass es flache Spieße sind,
die etwas Breite haben,
damit das Ganze eben auch gegrillt werden kann.
Also diese dünnen Holzspieße eigenen sich dafür nicht.
Und, was dann ganz wichtig ist,
vor dem Grillen einfach die Spieße einfrieren.
Ihr könnt sie wirklich auch super vorbereiten.
Daher, damit man wie bei Burger Buns
das Ganze erst mal fest bekommt
und sie beim Grillen dann nicht auseinanderfallen.
Okay. Ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen Oliven-
Sonnenblumenöl in die Hand.
Jetzt machen wir erst mal einen kleinen Spieß.
Burger Patties meine ich doch.
Och!
Und dann werden sie wie bei Burger Patties
einfach eingefroren, damit man sie besser grillen kann.
So. Jetzt machen wir erst mal einen kleinen Spieß.
Ein bisschen Öl in die Hand nehmen.
Aufspießen und schön flach drücken.
[Musik]
So.
Das erste Blech ist fertig
und wandert direkt ins Gefrierfach,
bis es eingefroren ist.
Jetzt mache ich noch den Rest fertig
und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder am Grill.
Nee, wir sehen uns vorher.
Denn ich bereite noch Zwiebelsalat zu
und mache nebenher noch ein Fladenbrot.
[Musik]
Bist du der Feuermann?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich mache gerade Adana-Spieße.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Guck.
Sieht das höchst professionell aus?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Schatz, in mir ist ein Kebab-Meister
verloren gegangen.
>> MURAT: Ja?
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ja, würde ich schon sagen.
[Musik]
Das Brot ist jetzt im Backofen.
Die Spieße sind im Gefrierfach.
Hier mache ich jetzt noch Zwiebelsalat.
Ich habe die Zwiebeln jetzt bereits fein gehobelt
beziehungsweise fein geschnitten.
Hier kommt Petersilie dazu.
Ordentlich Petersilie.
Dann viel Zitronensaft und etwas Olivenöl,
Salz, Pfeffer und Sumak.
Sumak ist Essigbaumgewürz.
Das passt auch perfekt.
Und dann haben wir gleich
die perfekt Kombination draußen beim Essen.
[Musik]
Unser Feuer draußen ist gleich bereit.
Wenn ihr aber nicht draußen grillen möchtet,
sondern lieber zu Hause,
könnt ihr es natürlich auch auf einer Grillplatte hier tun
oder ihr nehmt einfach eine Pfanne.
In einer Pfanne geht das auch.
Ich mache es jetzt hier auf der Grillplatte.
Da komm-
Ich habe die jetzt ein bisschen eingefettet.
Da kommen jetzt
die gefrorenen Spieße drauf.
Und erst, nachdem die Unterseite eine schöne Kruste hat,
werden sie gewendet,
damit einfach der Spieß nicht kaputtgeht.
Also wie
beim Burgerbraten, wie beim Patties-Braten eben auch
erst eine Kruste bilden lassen
und dann wenden.
[Musik]
Drinnen war es natürlich einfacher zu grillen.
Aber hier draußen geht es auch gut.
Also drinnen haben sie sich auch perfekt drehen lassen.
Ich hoffe, das funktioniert hier jetzt auch genauso gut.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Jetzt kommen die Riesenschwerter, hä?
>> SALLY: Eigentlich gibt es ja da
einen extra Adana-Grill dafür,
dass man die immer schön drehen kann,
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: dass die nicht anbrennen.
Wichtig ist im Prinzip nur,
dass der
der Grillrost...
Das Grillrost? Der Grillrost?
>> MURAT: Der Grillrost.
Dass das ein bisschen gefettet ist.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Aber jetzt ist es ja auch ideal,
weil der liegt ja nicht genau auf dem Grill auf.
>> SALLY: Genau. Genau.
Jetzt ist es gut.
So.
Und dann kann ich die schön wenden.
>> SALLY & MURAT: So.
>> SALLY: Dann kann das rein und das...
>> MURAT: Das sind die Schwerter der Königin?
Genial!
Wow!
>> SALLY: Dann können alle zum Essen kommen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kommen gleich alle nach draußen zum Essen.
Wir probieren schon mal, hä?
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Also
>> MURAT: Ela, warte kurz.
>> SALLY: ein bisschen Brot...
Also eigentlich macht man es in der Türkei,
man nimmt sich so einen Spieß,
der kommt einfach hier ins Brot,
>> MURAT: Und zieht ihn einfach ab, gell?
>> SALLY: zieht ihn ab
und dann Zwiebelsalat dazu
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> ELA: Ich möchte auch so was!
>> SALLY: Ja. Komm, Ela.
>> MURAT: Ja, du darfst auch gleich jemand abziehen.
>> SALLY: Ich liebe Zwiebelsalat mit Sumak!
>> MURAT: Boah, Josh! kannst du das mal reinfilmen, Josh?
Das sieht so cool aus!
Und jetzt mache ich noch ein bisschen Kartoffeln rein.
>> SALLY: Oh, ja!
>> MURAT: Das muss zwar nicht, aber geht.
Perfekt!
Ela, Achtung!
Ela, nicht unten reinbeißen!
Du willst unbedingt das Fleisch essen, ich weiß es.
Gib mal noch mal ein Stück, Schatzi.
>> SALLY: Für die Ela?
>> MURAT: So. Ja.
>> SALLY: Ich habe es auch nicht scharf gemacht
wegen der Ela
und wegen Samira.
>> MURAT: So.
Ich weiß, dass du Fleisch essen möchtest.
Hier.
Da.
>> SALLY: Ela, das Fleischkind!
Und?
Wie schmeckt es, Mäuschen?
>> ELA: Gut.
>> MURAT: Gut?
>> SALLY: Da, Schatz, probier bei mir.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Die Ela lässt dir nichts mehr übrig.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Hauptsache, Ela hat Fleisch und kann grillen.
>> MURAT: Hammer!
>> SALLY: Mega, nicht?
>> MURAT: Echt coole Sachen! Echt toll!
>> SALLY: Ja. Also ich hole jetzt unser restliches Team.
Jungs, Mädels, ihr könnt alle kommen!
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann wird jetzt gleich gegessen.
>> SALLY: Probiert das Rezept unbedingt mal aus!
Und schreibt mir euer Feedback!
Bis zum nächsten Mal!
Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Hammer!
[Musik]